- Today we're gonna talk
about my, my hot dad.
(upbeat music)
There was an email that
went around looking
for attractive dads and I
knew my dad was attractive.
A couple people replied
and then I dropped a bomb.
I literally, in the caption of the email,
said, "I couldn't bring him on field trips
"because all of my classmates
were just salivating
"over the man."
And what happens right
when I send that email?
A laundry list of multiple
people in this office
who can't contain themselves.
Bringing my dad around
ruined a lot of potential
relationships growing up.
He was very charismatic
and he had good style
so I constantly had to
deal with him in suits.
So I'm gonna be hiding on
the other side of this wall.
I'm just supposed to hear the
reactions from my co-workers
as they look through a gallery
of photos of my father.
I'm a little nervous.
I mean honestly I was like iffy
about this whole experience.
- So we basically heard
that Eli's dad is a baddie
and we wanted to you know
find out for ourselves.
- Mmm-hmm I wanna look at him.
- I've been single for a while.
I'm not ashamed to say that I'm thirsty
but I am gonna be ashamed
what it's gonna lead to.
- We're discussing Eli's
dad and I don't know
how I feel about it.
- A few years ago his dad
came to visit him in LA
and as a friend, oh you know,
I'd love to meet your dad.
And he's like, "No, stay
away you thirsty ..."
And I was like okay.
So I'm curious to see
why he was already trying
to thwart me off of his dad.
Let's take a look.
- Yep, bring me those pics.
Are there dick pics?
(record scratching)
- It's a very (mumbles) style.
- Yeah he looks like he chills at a bar.
- He looks a lot like Eli.
He's like got the slightly open mouth.
- Feel like he knows how cute he is.
- Uh huh, oh yep.
Oh yes!
(laughs)
Yes!
- I always thought that's
weird to call someone daddy,
like as in sexually.
- Yeah.
- It's kinda weird.
- Me too.
- He is someone's daddy.
(laughs)
- I now know why he was
telling me to stay away.
- We need a bring your father to work day.
- I don't know dude.
He's someone's dad.
I don't know.
- How come Eli don't
be dressin' like this?
- Is he a local?
- No I think he's in Texas.
- Ugh, you know what they say?
- Everything's bigger in Texas.
- Mmm-hmm.
(laughs)
- I don't know, I'm friends with Eli, man.
I would not date his dad
if purely off of respect
for my good friend Eli.
- [Female Announcer] I
actually have a surprise
for you guys.
- Shit.
- Oh my fucking God, no!
- No, he is not here.
- No!
- Get the fuck out!
(laughs)
- Daysha, you were my wife!
You know how fucked up that
is the things you were saying?
First off, you were my wife
so all this is disgusting.
- I said I wouldn't okay?
Matt was the one encouraging it.
- Secondly this is the
dirtiest things I've ever heard
come out of sweet, sweet Matt's mouth.
Kate gimme a hug.
That was so sweet.
(laughs)
I was honestly expecting
the worst from ...
- From me?
- I don't know why, I was
like "Oh shit, it's Kate."
- Oh no sweetie, of course not.
- I was worried about Chris
and what shook me the most
was the very beginning where
you said you don't know
what you would do out
of the outcome of this,
so I'm like, "Is he gonna
masturbate to my dad?"
I really didn't want, I was
like oh, he's from Texas.
Oh my God, fuck, I know,
I already know someone's
gonna fucking say the joke.
Don't say it.
- Everything's bigger in Texas.
- Mmm-hmm.
- And I'm like, yep, there he goes.
I love how you're avoiding everything.
Like oh, what is this
business behind there,
oh he's drinking a beer.
- Just know that I chose you.
- Just chose, you didn't even
know what he looked like.
- That is very true.
- Ugh, okay so I knew this would suck.
I was surprised when I
thought certain people
would be chill about it, they weren't.
And when I thought people
would just be nasty
they were really sweet about it.
- Good looking guy.
Got a nice complexion, he's
a really attractive man.
- Kate was honestly the
sweetest person ever.
- I would never date your dad buddy.
- That's great, I'd be
all like, you know what
my great friend Eli, I
wouldn't do something ...
And there's a puppy, oh my
God, friendship and puppies.
- Friendship and puppies.
- You don't get any sweeter than that.
Someone that respectful
while holding a puppy,
it's like the best combo ever.
I feel good because I get his great genes,
he's a loving father, sweet guy.
I'm lucky enough to have a young dad
that I can spend a lot of memories with.
Hopefully I look nearly as
good as him when I'm his age.
So I found out there's a
messaging thread going around
at the office and it was about my dad.
I'm seeing this for the first time.
Everyone's freaking the fuck out.
Where's the research team?
They're trying to find the research team
to figure out where's my dad.